ultimamente ho seguito con molta
attenzione le vicissitudini degli who e
6 e di trump e mi è venuto in mente di
fare un monologo su quello che stava
succedendo con brett cavano mano quelle
cose lì li lascio fare a quei canali di
attualità noiosissimi tipo break in
italy no io voglio roba più interessante
tipo melania trump che risponde alle
critiche sul suo cappello indossato in
kenya o donald che sale sull'aereo
presidenziale come un pezzo di carta ha
attaccato alla sola della sua scarpa e
voglio dire se quella viene considerata
una notizia vera questo può essere
considerato uno show ovvero sigla
[Musica]
benvenuti al nuovo episodio bellezza con
karim usa quanti di voi sapevano
dell'esistenza su youtube del canale
ufficiale della casa bianca con tanto di
verificato direi che più influenza e di
un influente c'è soltanto il presidente
degli stati uniti almeno finché putin
non si decida di aprirne uno suo
underscore putin underscore lukoil foto
del profilo lui insieme a fedor emilia
nemico o lui insieme a jean claude van
damme o lui insieme a steven seagal
io mi iscriverei i contenuti caricati
dalla casa bianca sono molto vari vanno
da briefing con la stampa interviste a
diverse personalità politiche e non
la first lady melania che visita vari
posti più o meno importanti e ovviamente
trump che va per esempio a controllare
il prototipo del muro a confine con il
messico
una bella musica il progetto
fortunatamente sembra procedere bene un
muro per tenere lontani gli immigrati ed
eventualmente qualche cai giu ma
soprattutto trump una buona web star che
si rispetti
fai un wiki blog dove racconta i
maggiori avvenimenti appunto della
settimana però vorrei farvi notare una
cosa questa è l'anteprima dell'ultimo
weekly questa quella del penultimo e
quindi mi è venuto un dubbio
vuoi vedere che chi gestisce il canale
della casa bianca
odia profondamente donald si odia
calzano sembra uno di quei depliant che
serve per scegliere il colore delle
piastrelle da mettere immagino lo dico
io lo dico lo dico e molto bello 50
sfumature di trump l'ho detta l'aspetto
ma come ci sono finito su questo canale
come probabilmente vi ricorderete a
febbraio c'è stata l'ennesima sparatoria
in una scuola superiore a park lane in
florida dove un diciannovenne ha ucciso
a colpi di arma da fuoco 17 persone tra
studenti e insegnanti e quindi per far
vedere che il governo americano non
rimane con le mani in mano in questi
momenti di tragedia
cosa fa quello che farebbe qualsiasi
governo per salvaguardare la sua gente
mostrerebbe un montaggio né di un minuto
e mezzo di videogiochi violenti
e non voglio entrare nel merito della
demonizzazione dei videogiochi violenti
perché è un argomento noioso ha rotto le
balle diventato veramente stantio
ogni volta che succede qualcosa i media
si accaniscono contro il mondo
videoludico
lo sappiamo ricordo alcuni servizi
italiani che definirono gta il gioco in
cui per fare più punti devi ammazzare le
prostitute per fare più punti
così posso diventare il bambino più fico
del 1982
mi sono anche stancato di leggere
persone incazzate sui social per questo
abbiamo capito solo superficiali quando
parlano dei videogiochi dyck voglio dire
se bastasse guardare una forma di
intrattenimento per essere capaci di
farla saremo tutti dei maghi a letto ma
non è così e così non ridere non è così
mi vorrei soffermare un secondo sul
video caricato dalla casa bianca
ovviamente è stato accolto da
numerosissime critiche tra le quali sono
confuso questo è il nuovo canale l'ex
play di trump la casa bianca è stata
appena de monetizzata e io pago le tasse
per questo è quest ultimo commento è
molto ironico perché questo video prima
di essere tolto dall'elenco visibile dei
video furbacchioni ha fatto in pochi
giorni un milione e quattrocentomila
visual mentre un vedo di trump e dove
parla effettivamente di come riformare
ed abbassare le tasse ne ha fatti a
malapena 30.000 tieni america questa
questa è la definizione di priorità e mi
raccomando usala come più ti aggrada ma
la cosa più strana è proprio il
contenuto di quel video che non è altro
che un montaggio lineare di scene
violente di vari videogiochi senza
nessuno che spiegasse qualcosa è tutto
completamente fuori contesto
tralasciando il sempre verde call of
duty che se fosse una persona sarebbe
una prostituta con in mano un cartello
con scritto picchiatemi che tanto è
sempre colpa mia
ci sono anche band by day light e dei
volumi team
[Musica]
e per chi non fosse avvezzo di
videogiochi quelli sono due giochi con i
mostri dentro iniziare a sparare in una
scuola avendo giocato ad un gioco horror
sarebbe come imparare a cantare
ascoltando un solo dentro sawyer bhatti
puoi provare ma se come ci sono metodi
migliori
e tutto questo mi ha fatto pensare ad
una cosa e se fosse vero e se ci fosse
veramente una relazione tra videogiochi
violenti e sparatorie persino bin laden
aveva una libreria di steam è piena di
giochi dove si sparava qualche cazzo di
cosa vorrà dire
quindi la domanda ed io essendo
cresciuto negli anni 90 cioè nel periodo
d'oro dove i videogiochi si sparava ad
altre persone riuscirei a tenere un arma
in mano magari pure con una certa
precisione potrebbe veramente bastare
con call of duty qualsiasi per rendere
me nuovo capace di puntare la pistola
un'altra persona è riuscire ad andare a
segno con il colpo io c'ho pure origini
arabe quindi scopriamolo
[Musica]
prendiamo i pallini va bene userai per i
bersagli di genola
quello che non vuole la pistola e la
forza muscolare
siamo qui al poligono di tiro per
provare appunto questa cosa se riesco a
tenere in mano un'arma senza spezzarmi
l'avambraccio e riuscire a colpire un
bersaglio ed è interessante perché io
non posso provare armi da fuoco perché
non ho la licenza e quindi posso provare
solo armi ad aria compressa trump
risolto l'america basterebbe questa
costa in baby prova ok adesso che niro
su riguarda dove secolo
[Musica]
quindi la mano nella tasca o nella
cintura
ok e stato questo il mio secondo colpo
ufficiale mi si muove ancora parecchio
la mano comunque vero st mascara
attenzione comunque anti nei fatti 4 cc
è così e ne è messo un'ora nel bianco sì
diciamo come scopriamo contentare 2 e 1
non so come sia finito completamente
smontata
questo sì un setter e i suoi possiamo
chiamarle morti sul campo cantiere come
no morte sul tavolo procediamo le
persone contro potrà vedere una cosa
tanto siamo in pausa ci sono un sacco di
regole da seguire tra l'altro di
posizioni il respiro ai piedi le spalle
la schiena e tra l'altro ho potuto
provare sia la pistola ad aria compressa
che la carabina ad aria compressa
dai dai dai
pantalone sentirò ma carabina pesa 5
chili vestiti non li abbiamo mandati via
ma la carabina
ma farsi del certo ti faccio vedere come
l'apertura della frase così lui firma
all'interno molto meglio però insomma ho
colpito da un po meglio un po meglio che
abbiamo fatto
quindi per rispondere alla domanda so
sparare anche solo tenere in mano
un'arma avendo visto solo film è giocato
a videogiochi sparatutto ci sono una
marea di regole ovviamente non è che
pensa a un prete nei voli di arrivare
con prendere la pistola e sparare io no
ci sono delle regole da seguire 6
supervisionate ok però ventura è molto
dura perché non è soltanto il prendere
la mira con l'occhio ma è una serie di
variabili incredibile i muscoli della
respirazione le bene i piedi suoi le
ginocchia stanno morendo andato alla
giacca di michael jackson pesava 10 kit
fa però devo dire che e stai non so se
potrei dirlo è stato divertente sparare
a dei bersagli di carta o è vero non
quello che posso mentire è stato
divertente bene alla fine è andata così
male
sto sparando al dischetto grigio che c'è
lì nel nero per tirare su tutte le
paperelle e poi spara le proprie le però
la paperella la più grande loro
mannaggia
grillo
[Musica]